hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your math grade
improve your understanding and hopefully
make math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to find the surface area of
a prism and of a cylinder now I group
these together prisms and cylinders
because they're very similar it's like a
prism is basically you have two parallel
and congruent faces like this and
they're separated by the height okay so
for a cylinder cylinder basically has
two circles that are parallel and
congruent through the same size and
shape separated by the height and you
can see here is a square prism you have
two squares that are separated by the
height and they're the same size and
shape okay so to find the surface area
of a prism you take two times the area
of the base that's what the capital B
represents plus the perimeter of the
base that's so the P represents times
the height so the way this works is if
you cut this and you unfold it okay
you're going to end up with a big
rectangle like so and you're going to
have a top and a bottom so two squares I
folded those like that so if you were to
fold it back up you fold these and these
would wrap around and that would form
the the sides or what they call the
lateral area but what we can do is we
can find the area of this base okay
these two bases and you can see it's a
square it's over here this is four by
four so that's going to be 16 okay for
the area of the base times two because
we have two of them so that's 2 times 16
plus now that what's the formula for the
area of a rectangle well it's a length
times width or base times height right
but you can see here the height is 8
this base is actually the perimeter
okay the perimeter of the base so this
is actually 4 4 4 and 4 that gives you
16 times the height times 8 so that's
going to give you 8 times 16 okay so if
you simplify that all out what do we get
looks like we get 32 plus 128 which is a
hundred and sixty units squared okay so
for area it's a square units because
you're covering this with like little
one by one by one
squares like you're wrapping a present
with little little squares right
okay now this one with the cylinder
imagine if we cut this open okay it's
like a roll and you unroll it flip the
top up flip the top down or the base
here downs you're going to get two
circles and a rectangle so that's easy
enough you find the area of the circle
PI R squared so this case is going to be
PI times 5 squared times 2 because you
have a top and a bottom okay now this
part here can be a little bit
challenging okay this is a rectangle
right but where does this dimension here
come from it comes from the
circumference of the circle the
circumference of the base so when you
cut this and you unroll it this length
is actually the circumference 2 pi R
okay so what we're taking is we're
taking the this length 2 pi R times the
height to give us the area of the
rectangle so length times width or base
times height but this represents the
circumference of the circle okay so
that's 2 times pi times the radius is 5
times the height which is 10 and if we
simplify this we get 25 times 2 which is
50 PI plus 50 times 2 is a hundred pi so
we're looking at 150 PI units squared
again square units because this is just
area area is a two-dimensional you're
covering this with little squares so I
hope you learn something from this video
I hope this made finding surface area of
prisms and cylinders a little bit easier
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and stay tuned for
some future videos I'll see you in the
next video